Shawn is with us in New York - how are
you hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up hey okay I'm new
listener and just started on the verge
to try to get in out of get into
financial freedom cool
my I listen to the statement the seven
baby steps and I completed baby step one
within two months
my question is any advice for that
person that's really scared to jump into
baby step two um without only having one
income what do you what are you scared
of um like I have a few dollars in like
three other accounts oh how much more do
you have um I would say about two
thousand dollars and three separate
accounts I so lowering that down to one
thousand dollars well that's beside the
thousand dollars that I have saved okay
so you have two thousand dollars above
your $1,000 correct and moving on
towards debt and only having one
thousand dollar scares you yes okay and
what is your household income uh forty
mm okay all right and how much debt do
you have sir 4,200 okay well how quickly
would you be debt-free if we put two
thousand on the forty two hundred that
would only leave you 2200 making $42,000
a year how fast would you be debt-free
in about four months yeah or two about
it a month then two to four months okay
and then if you didn't have any debt
payments how quickly could you build
your account back up to two thousand
dollars more to three in other words I
mean it let's sudden money
yeah now two months now yeah if you if
you paid off the debt a $2,000 in two
months that's $1,000 a month you should
be able to save $1,000 a month easy
after that happens so total of about
four months is all we're talking about
difference in where you are now
I'm just afraid not to have a security
blanket there months single for four
months mmm it's not like you got a big
security blanket no not at all I mean
it's not much of one so it's not like
weird like going 20 grand out or
something that would be an emotional
discussion it's two grand I you know I
listen I I have found I have found that
two or three things happen when people
get out of debt and change their lives
and that includes me when I decide I'm
going to change some portion of my life
I have to decide I'm going to do it and
then I have to commit to do something
I've never done and it's almost always
uncomfortable to reset your behavior
patterns and reset your habits and reset
your life it almost always takes you out
of your comfort zone doesn't it yes okay
so you know what I think I think I think
this is going to scare you in a good way
enough that you're going to get your
butt in gear and get this mess cleaned
up fast because you're not going to like
living this way and I'm not really
asking you to do something that's that
risky it's not but I listen to everyone
and they basically get out of trouble to
get out of debt really quickly but I
don't know why I'm still nervous and
taking that second step you know I've
been listening to the financial makeover
the only way I'm able to do it but it it
still scares me to just be able to pay
off my car and not have any money for
any money saved up well we're not doing
this for five years we're doing it for a
month a whole frickin month I mean we'll
really do you look at it that way you
know it's not I mean because two months
the debts gone right so it's actually a
lot it's three months I'm asking to it
because the third month you put a
thousand back more and the fourth month
you put another thousand back more and
by the way the fail month another
thousand until you get this built up to
a good emergency fund so that by the
time you and I are talking this time
next year you not only have no debt you
have a fully funded emergency fund and
now you started investing okay so should
I stop and
vesting stop adding money into small
accounts down temporarily until you get
this dadgum debt gone because debt is
your wealth killer your number one
ability to build wealth is your income
and when you spend your income at the
bank you've killed your ability to build
wealth have you noticed that the bank's
building is bigger than yours have you
noticed their furniture is nicer than
yours it's because you give them all
your money
it's how that works and so when you get
out of the world of credit cards and car
payments you suddenly have cash it's an
amazing thing I you know you can do what
you want to do sir I'm honored to have
you as a listener that's my
recommendation or I to wake up in your
shoes I would do it so fast it would be
unbelievable and I would I would just
get on it and you're just you're single
you're not talking buy into this
he's got talk the guy in the mirror in
to straighten his act up no you just
yell at Sean no Sean you can't go out to
eat no Sean you gotta get some money
back in the ring no we gotta get rid of
debt shun no Sean you can't spend money
on that get off Amazon Prime no Sean
don't go to Walmart no you don't need to
keep Target open no stay out there
buying those miscellaneous kitchen items
you only know what they do it's
unbelievable I mean you have a drawer
full of miscellaneous kitchen items that
you haven't used in five years some
bread maker or processing crap that you
thought you had to have to live no don't
buy that stuff for that matter ever but
certainly while you're getting out of
debt hey thanks for the call sir hey you
guys Rachael Cruz here hope you're
enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and did
you know that I have my very own YouTube
channel yes that's right kind of better
save room to channel tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you